hello reject ville or schmoeville or
whoever happens to be watching today
I'm Greg Alva this is John de roca Nader
the outlaw you sons-of-bitches outlaw we
allow the customer we can locate
fuckballs come whatever we want to say
today John its Tourette I've been
wanting John Roca movie trivia showdown
champion to come on this channel for a
while I wanted you to come on before you
got the belt yeah and then you got the
belt then I got extra nervous to ask you
to come long as you had the belt was I
didn't but now he's here today you can
follow him on Twitter Instagram he's got
so much in the works right now the
outlaw nation show on the shows no I
wrote everything down on my phone got
there what else do you on John well no
yeah every Friday up on Collider movie
talk at 10 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
and then I do the cinephiles podcast
with my film professor friend Steve
Morris that's on Twitter I've been on
iTunes and on stitcher and we have a
YouTube channel as well for that where
you can go and just listen to the audio
of those episodes if you don't want to
do podcasts and of course outlaw nation
is about to debut I talked about those
no-show a couple of weeks ago it's going
to debut soon we're going to do a bunch
of segments punch it up it's basically
what are you angry about the world when
you pass them out the world let's talk
about it on outlaw nation everything he
said that John Humphrey and I will come
on the show if you love us this is this
is the certification right here this
proof we're going to be about your your
need to be validated for creating the
reaction review YouTube first is about
is very all I know yeah that's all I
care about
hey you've been to Detroit John uh-uh no
I've never been to Detroit me neither
but I know Eminem has its Kathryn
Bigelow done a new movie out there all
right go watch this trailer let's do it
then we'll review it how's it going to
be the videos only to say to you my more
the city's west side
I wanted a 50 block area is off-limits
to everybody
- as a strippers National Guardsman
state and local police okay are
continuing the fight against a handful
of sniper ran fine trouble bit I'll
sleep when they stop riding a fell it's
damned on their grocery store across the
street
I've come bearing gifts thank you yeah
sure
what's your name oh thank you for sent
down
they're destroying the city boy y'all
see in this and let me out to talk about
weird let's go down to all his little
top black is almost like having a gun
moving like this hey what you doing on
my street detecting or what whoa you
think so yeah I'm nearly out there boo
tell the police
oh my god this really happened let's not
be stupid in the situation like a
revenant you need to tell me where the
gun is
I got all nice people tell me exactly
what is going on here
[Music]
[Music]
know what this is referencing another
student in history will block Wow
destroy
[Music]
you know any movie I can take place in
Detroit just make the chart look like
the worst place I'd like have no desire
a gutter teacher right I will however a
lot of people do talk trash about
Detroit yeah I would attend Strahler I
know
Kathryn Bigelow's direct I mean her
style direction is like the handheld and
you know yeah I'm reminiscent of Paul
Greengrass of style yeah but I still
feel she's going for something much more
specific a different type of artistic
direction because at first I wasn't sure
if this was like a film from the 60s or
70s at first it was like it's kind of
looking like yeah and then you see that
takes place in the 60s and seeing that
she's capturing a very specific time
frame yeah it looks like she's doing a
very good job at the authenticity with
it yeah it's a great cup of archival
footage and footage too and then
obviously stuff that she shot you know
and you get John boyega coming in here
which i think is fantastic I yeah this
is the thing that is about English
actors they will automatically do New
York or southern that's something
evident so to hear John wagga do a very
good American accent that doesn't have
that kind of Kate Winslet twist to it
yeah sometimes these British actors can
do I'm very impressed by this and this
book this is a great little kind of
departure for him from doing the big
Star Wars thing I like he's an actual
actor Lee yeah to do this cuz I've been
I've been wondering where he's going
with his career yeah
is that when he did attack a block and
he comes out with Star Wars and he has
this like supporting role in that circle
movie with Tommy nice but I wasn't sure
like what direction is decisions in
Pacific Rim 2 as well that's right
so this looks like a great and great
opportunity for him and anyone who's in
a Kathryn Bigelow film gets like a ton
of praise we have performances yeah you
knows how to bring out solid performance
yeah that's like Anthony Mackie is back
to with him coming off there he was in
the company Mackie was in this yeah if
he would think you as well these guys
had his hands live his back and if I say
I think I saw him in there and not great
to see how so much film and TV within
like the black lives matter movement
yeah I think so much is capitalizing on
the capitalizing - right word but not
really saying the message out there from
how this street is black people a bit
well this is something that film does
right every film reflects what's
happening
the country but the Moody's in the
country with stuff that's coming off of
Ferguson and stuff that's coming with
the Michael Brown murder like all this
kind of stuff that the black lives
matter like you just mentioned Greg this
is what's happening in the country like
it or not this is what it has a
calendaring app this is I've never even
heard of this story so I love the
tagline it's time we knew that's like so
there are many levels to it good point
because yeah I'm watching like I'm not
familiar in all of what they're
portraying right but yet it feels like a
very essential and important story to be
viewing right now at this point what's
that guy's name who you pointed out got
from at the revenant every day Macke
then Jackie notice John Krasinski ha
this movie's gonna be funny
I think it's Poulter will Poulter will
Poulter no he's in we're the Millers oh
yeah that's right plays Madhu - gets his
bowls gripped by the spider and that's
right and he's in great to be there why
don't we switch up anyway you was
supposed John's over Humphreys over
there yeah mate he's in the maze
remember this guy was just said no I'm
not knowing but I guess we be kid now as
an adult
yes you an adult he's an English actor -
I had no idea yeah holy crap all these
actors have guessed right for Gotham I'm
glad American memories guard out of the
way and set messages about the world and
[ __ ] but Castle [ __ ] Americans once in
a while will you
I love the way the trailer begins to it
immediately is like poopoo like it just
puts you right now this is going to be
very serious
tough pill yeah and then that got some
big look falling that's captain Bigelow
ringing my bell
thank you for doing this reaction okay
right now what I'll go back to equipped
with the tagline the tagline has a lot
of levels because not just its time we
knew about this story it's time we knew
about this fury idlife of happening in
this country that's been happening for
decades Natalie if you watch that OJ
Simpson documentary that they don't ESPM
they really explore how deep the race
issues have been with police and black
communities for decades in this class if
you haven't seen hojae made in America
dudes because he is crazy because it's
like the police community the black
community and then john-boy is playing a
black officer in destroy go ahead
is crazy to make yeah isn't me other
what to learn I'm magic mr. Ryder
like Jim cuts come in handy he wrote The
Hurt Locker at zero dark thirty oh these
are going to be it's this is going to be
another intense uncomfortable experience
this is one thing these do when they
come together yeah they know how to put
you right in the moment make it real
can be kind of slow sometimes for the
average moviegoer that's the thing is
like she's dealt with war territory a
lot this is like a different kind of war
zone and one of the straight years I
don't know one has become war no you are
what yeah whole thing with being sort of
being initiated by starter pistol like
that's the thing you know it's and I
like that that actor is still is working
consistently the guy who played eazy-e
Straight Outta Compton I enjoyed him in
Kong Skull Island and I came here but
like this whole idea I'm like what we
hear all the time these stories like oh
he pulled out a toy pistol that's how
the stuff when that's on edge
any little thing and push you over and
go somewhere something solidified yeah
cuz that scene when they're all just
[ __ ] around out of the room and
they're shooting the gun you're like why
are you doing that and then everyone
starts blazing guns like holy [ __ ] this
happened yeah all because of just one
gun shine yeah that's insane well back
in the 60s we didn't have a lot of due
process but some unfortunate is to say
the least
thank you guys for everyone who tuned in
I appreciate it so much I like most of
you subscribe to the real rejects Jean
Roca you can follow on Twitter and
Instagram everything we mentioned
earlier can you send me some links so I
can put them in the other bottle will
make my life easier follow me at the
Roca says or OCA writing says yes he's
movie trivia Schmo down champ and this
was requested first person out of with
many goliath warfare
oh the first one to request is Goliath
warfare which is what Roca names his
parents that's true
yeah I gotta lie to you Callaghan laugh
warfare is coming in wait what